ein russischer Raketenangriff auf das
Dorf rosa vergangenen Donnerstag in der
Ostukraine mindestens 5 Menschen sterben
die Einwohner hatten sich nach einer
Beerdigung in einem Restaurant zur
Trauerfeier versammelt es ist der
bislang schwerste Angriff auf ein
ziviles ukrainisches Ziel in diesem
Jahr meine Mama ist gestorben mein
Bruder und meine
Schwägerin ich kann einfach nicht ich
will dass diese russischen Faschisten
endlich vernichtet
werden in der Ukraine befürchten die
Menschen dass der Terror Russlands
weitergeht von der Welt aber nicht mehr
so wahrgenommen wird wie bisher weil
inzwischen Israel Opfer des Terrors
geworden
ist es ist das gleiche übel das auch uns
heimesucht hat der einzige Unterschied
ist Israel von ein terrorischen tion
angegriffen wurde und wir Opfer eines
terroristischen Staates sind der die
Ukraine angreift wir sehen das gleiche
Blut auf den Straßen die gleichen
zerschossenen Zivilfahrzeuge die
gleichen Leichen von Menschen die
gefoltert
wurden in Moskau fordert ausgerechnet
der russische Außenminister ein Ende der
Gewalt in Israel und meint nach einem
Treffen mit der Arabischen Liga die
Ukraine hätte vom Westen gelieferte
Waffen auf dem Schwarzmarkt an
Terroristen weiterverkauft
Waffen werden in großen Mengen an die
Ukraine geliefert und gelangen weltweit
in die Hände von Schmugglern und anderen
skrupellosen Händlern dieser tödlichen
Güter das ist ein lange bekannter
Fakt unterdessen meldet der ukrainische
Militärgeheimdienst das Russland in
Hamas Terroristen trophenwaffen
übergeben hat die während der Kämpfe in
der Ukraine erbeutet und in den USA und
der EU hergestellt
unabhängig bestätigt ist das nicht doch
tatsache ist dass ramaschef Ismail hanie
im September
2022 und im März dieses Jahres nach
Moskau reiste für Gespräche mit
Russlands Außenminister
lavrov wir haben beobachtet wie häufig
die Hamas nach Moskau reist es geht um
die Destabilisierung westlicher
Demokratien und hier wurde durch die
Hamas Israel in einem schwächemoment
angegriffen und die Hamas alleine kann
dies nicht leisten der Hintergrund wird
in Teheran sitzen und sicherlich auch in
enger Abstimmung mit
Moskau Putin Sprecher Dimitri Peskow
frohlockt über die angebliche Schwäche
des
Westens es gibt emotionale
Ermüdungserscheinungen und berechtigte
Fragen ausländischer Steuerzahler wofür
das Geld für die Ukraine eigentlich
ausgegeben
wird der Kremmel beobachtet sehr genau
wie gespalten inzwischen die Staaten
Europas sind auf der einen Seite
Slowakei und Ungarn die eher wie
Marionetten Putins wirken und auf der
anderen Seite USA die dringend mehr
europäische Entlastung brauchen und dass
natürlich jetzt die Aufmerksamkeit in
Richtung Israel geht zurecht aber
Russland setzt auch darauf dass dann die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine nachlässt
und schlägt dann unerbärmlich zu die USA
wollen den größten Flugzeugträger der
Welt in das östliche Mittelmeer schicken
die Welt blickt jetzt in diese Region
und weniger auf die
Ukraine seit dem Sommer hat die
ukrainische Armee beachtliche Erfolge
und zwar im Süden wie die Vernichtung
eines hochmodernen luftabwehrsystems
S400 auf der
Krim die Krim wurde von Russland bereits
2014 völkerrechtswidrig annektiert in
Sevastopol ist die russische
Schwarzmeerflotte
stationiert die ukrainische Armee
profitiert von Untergrund auf der Krim
sie wehren sich gegen die russischen
Besatzer es sind Bestien und wir werden
sie
vernichten sie spionieren aus welche
Kriegsschiffe in Sevastopol anlanden
veröffentlichen Fotos und
Koordinaten Anfang September melden Sie
das Uboot rostoff am Don sei nach
Sevastopol
gekommen am 13 septemberchießen
ukrainische tren dieer igen das ub-boot
schwer Partisanen spielen gerade im
Süden eine Rolle für die Ukraine
Partisanen
bestechen Mitglieder der russischen
Streitkräfte der Schwarzmeerflotte mit
Geld um an Informationen über Treffen
über
auslaufzeitpunkte von Schiffen etc zu
kommen so kam es zum bislang größten
Angriff der Ukraine auf die Krim Attacke
auf die Kommandozentrale der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte am 22 September mit
drei
Marschflugkörpern die Bilder von
Sebastopol wo man eindeutigen britischen
marfelkörper sieht der auf das
Hauptquartier der der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte Mittel in svastopol
runterrattert und dann dieses Gebäude in
Trümmer legt das sind Bilder die
wahrscheinlich in den Geschichtsbüchern
über diesen Krieg auch vorkommen werden
zahlreiche russische Offiziere saßen
während des Angriffs zusammen die
Information darüber hatten grundkämpfer
durch Bestechung erhalten wie sie
ironisch auf ihrem telegramkanal
Posten ein besonderer Dank geht an das
Verteidigungsministerium der Russischen
Föderation die verspäteten Zahlungen an
das Militär helfen uns Offiziere der
Schwarzmeerflotte
anzuwerben doch die beste Spionage der
Untergrundkämpfer nutzt wenig wenn die
ukrainischen Truppen nicht genügend
Waffen haben zum Einsatz kamen
britisch-französische Marschflugkörper v
Typ Storm Shadow doch solche Waffen sind
rar bei den Briten und den Franzosen
wachsen die marf Körper natürlich auch
nicht auf den Bäumen und deshalb ist die
Ukraine froh um jeden anderen
Lieferanten der ein System liefert das
eben weiter in die russische Tiefe
reicht die Deutschen haben was die
Ukrainer so dringend brauchen den
Marschflugkörper Taurus er ist rund 5 m
lang hat hinten ein jettriebwerk und in
der Mitte den Sprengstoff ummantelt von
400 kg Spezialstahl zum Durchschlagen
von
Bunkern den taurusmarsch Flugkörper
könnte die Ukraine gerade jetzt
besonders gut gebrauchen denn in der
Ukraine beginnt bald die Schlammperiode
Panzer kommen dann nur noch schwer voran
die Taurus werden von Kampfjets
ausgestartet und können auch bei starkem
Schneefall oder Unwettern Ziele präzise
Treffen mit einer Reichweite von 500 km
könnten taurusmarschflugkörper die
Brücke von Kersch zerstören sie
verbindet die Krim mit dem russischen
Festland und ist ein wichtiger
Versorgungsweg für die russische
Armee mit Taurus ist es möglich die
russischen Versorgungslinien zusammen
mit unseren Verbündeten abzuschneiden
und die Russen auf der Krim zur Aufgabe
zu zwingen die Ukraine hat erkannt dass
die Krim nicht nur der Ausgangspunkt des
furchtbaren Terrors ist sondern dass mit
der Krim auch das Schicksal Putins
verknüpft ist wenn die Krim fällt fällt
auch Putin seit Monaten bittet die
ukrainische Führung Deutschland um die
Lieferung von
taurusmarschflugkörpern doch die
Bundesregierung
zögert der Regierungssprecher betont in
der Bundespressekonferenz gestern vor
allem die bisherige Unterstützung
Deutschlands für die
Ukraine ist es so dass wir darauf
hingewiesen haben dass es gewisse
verfassungsrechtliche Fragen sich
stellen wenn es um die Lieferung des
taurussystems dreht können Sie das
Ausführen welche verfassungsrechtlichen
Bedenken es gegen die Lieferung der
Taurus gibt ich würde Ihnen da
aufmerksame Zeitungslektüre empfehlen
und viel mehr kann ich von dieser Stelle
leider nicht dazu beitragen das ist
einfach eine schlichtweg eine
Schutzbehauptung nämlich man liefert
diese Marschflugkörper genauso wie man
Panzer liefert und übergibt sie der
Ukraine es braucht da sozusagen keine
Bundeswehr sooldaten es braucht da
überhaupt niemand nämlich die
ukrainische Armee und der ukrainischen
Soldaten sind gut genug um mit den
Waffen umzugehen doch der
Koalitionspartner SPD steht nach wie vor
auf der
Bremse dass Deutschland in der Frage die
riesiken abwägt zurückhaltenend ist
gemeinsam mit den Amerikanern übrigens
auch sich abstimmt finde ich vernünftig
und richtig und die mehr der Bevölkerung
üs auch amerikanische attackams Raketen
auch eine Fernwaffe um die Kiev gebeten
hat Washington wird demnächst 60 Stück
davon an die Ukraine liefern das könnte
auch ein Signal an Deutschland sein
Taurus zu liefern und möglicherweise
dafür sorgen dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine verkürzt
wird damit Russland nicht immer wieder
solche Greueltaten an der ukrainischen
Zivilbevölkerung verüben
kann